[Music]
breaking news this Wednesday a Canadian
military helicopter missing off the
coast of Greece the search-and-rescue
operation underway moving ahead more
provinces announced plans to relax some
restrictions and in the u.s. fears the
death toll could be significantly higher
than reported Colvig 19 consequences the
cost to Canadian businesses as BC
restaurants proposed a recipe to reopen
were probably down about 90 percent in
revenue striking the balance between
safety and success and optimism in
flooded Fort McMurray ice jams are
beginning to clear what could be a
turning point in a community that's been
through too much
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with breaking news
nato has confirmed it is investigating
an incident involving a canadian
military helicopter that's gone missing
off the coast of greece it was taking
part in a NATO mission there flying off
the back of HMCS Fredericton which is
based in Halifax Ross Lord is in Halifax
tonight Ross what more can you tell us
well Donna specifically NATO is saying
there's a search-and-rescue operation
under way involving a helicopter from a
ship under NATO command but the Canadian
forces are now confirming contact was
lost with a cyclone helicopter as it was
deployed off HMCS Fredericton reports in
Greek media say the helicopter went
missing between Greece and Italy the
Fredericton was deployed in January and
has been conducting maneuvers in the
waters around Europe it made a port of
call in Italy around the time the
pandemic broke out there the military
decided the frigate could complete its
mission in spite of the virus so they're
halfway through a six-month deployment
in the Mediterranean part of something
called Operation reassurance aimed at
supporting NATO in Central and Eastern
Europe as for the Cyclones
they're relatively new they replaced the
old seeking helicopters and they act as
a frigates operators on these overseas
deployments they typically carry between
four and eight people Canadian Forces
says as it's an evolving situation it
has no further information at this time
okay Ross Lord in Halifax thank you now
to the Cova Dean crisis there are more
signs parts of this country are
cautiously moving to relax some of the
restrictions we're living under what's
changing really depends on where you
live there are huge regional differences
in how Kovac 19 is spreading and being
contained and that impacts how provinces
are responding more than 1500 new cases
were reported across the country today
in some places though the number of new
cases has slowed to a trickle or stopped
completely
New Brunswick recorded its 11th straight
day with no new cases but Premier Blaine
Higgs remains cautious he has banned all
temporary foreign workers even
many farmers rely on them just this week
we're seen reports that Singapore which
had a great deal of success in fighting
the virus early on has suddenly had a
huge increase of cases this spike has
been attributed to temporary foreign
workers and in the country we cannot
allow a similar situation to happen here
in New Brunswick Quebec is still the
hardest hit province recording more than
eight hundred and thirty new cases today
most of them are in long-term care homes
so are the deaths so that province is
pushing ahead though with plans to
reopen daycares primary schools and some
retail businesses it also plans to ease
some travel restrictions within the
province Ontario reported three hundred
and twenty-four new confirmed cases
today that's the lowest daily increase
in three weeks but Premier Doug Ford
says it is still too soon to set a
timeline for reopening I'm just not
going to chance it we've worked so hard
we've come so far in this fight and all
of a sudden we're just gonna start
rolling rolling it out we're gonna do it
responsibly thoughtfully and cautiously
in Manitoba there is good news tonight
for people needing a haircut or a trip
to the dentist a number of non-essential
businesses will be allowed to reopen on
Monday Eric Sorenson looks at the
progress being made in Manitoba and the
patchwork of plants across the country
Manitoba turns towards a new normal on
Monday a province where there are four
times as many recovered cases as active
cases of kovat 19 today's good news the
premier announced Manitoba can now open
gradually next week many retail
businesses restaurant patios and hair
salons can open non urgent surgeries can
resume medical services day camps can
open it'll be another month though to
dine inside restaurants and non contact
children's sports is coming all made
possible because Manitobans kept their
distance and says the premier kept calm
for all you've shown each other in the
country through your strength and your
empathy and your courage Manitoba is not
alone New Brunswick is allowing families
to socialize with one other household
almost all New Brunswick ovid patients
have now recovered our goal all along
then to flatten the curve and we are
achieving that right now the curve is
flattening even in Quebec and Ontario a
little bit sharper rise in Alberta but
for British Columbia and several other
provinces the numbers are tailing off
now here are the number of confirmed
cases for the month of April Quebec has
by far the most Ontario second most but
that's not just because of the biggest
populations if you look at it per capita
it really breaks into three groups six
provinces are doing relatively well
starting with British Columbia with 20
cases per 100,000 population over the
month of April plus Saskatchewan
Manitoba New Brunswick Prince Edward
Island and Newfoundland and Labrador all
of their cases have been coming down now
there's that second group that are
fighting persistent outbreaks led by
Ontario with 90 cases per capita along
with Alberta and Nova Scotia which have
seen their numbers rise more recently
and then of course there is Quebec where
they have by far the most cases and the
most cases per capita it is a struggle
day by day in Quebec some worry Quebec
is being hasty sending kids to school
next month provinces with smaller or
rural populations do benefit from less
density but should not assume they're in
the clear you are in danger some
provinces are doing better others not
but the advice remains the same keep
your distance
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto in
Toronto three staff at an emergency
child care center for children of
essential workers have tested positive
for kovat 19 that facility has
temporarily shut down as two other staff
and two children await their test
results the center is one of about a
hundred and forty operating in Ontario
for essential workers without childcare
parents of young kids can't return to
work well after what happened yesterday
in child care a small incident in one of
the places I want all childcare workers
tested as well I want to protect our
children that's that's our number one
priority make sure they're safe
Nizar figuring out how to survive and
how to adjust their operations so they
can safely reopen some new data was
released today about the state of
Canadian businesses there's also
concerned about how outbreaks of kovat
19 inside some big beef and pork
processing plants in Canada and the u.s.
might impact the food supply chain david
aiken is tracking the government
response tonight david well Donna Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau did not offer
any specific plans to deal with the
supply chain problems affecting beef and
pork products government is still
talking with the industry but the Prime
Minister did say that the safety of
workers in those processing plants is at
least as important as making sure
there's enough hamburger and bacon on
grocery store shelves the priority for
us is both things keeping people safe
and ensuring a good supply of food to
Canadians we will make sure we're doing
them both together
david says Canada has compiled data with
the cooperation of the Canadian Chamber
of Commerce about the impact the
shutdowns
have had on a whole range of businesses
what does it reveal well Donna no
surprises here this pandemic has hit
business very hard stat scan says half
of all businesses in Canada have
recorded revenue declines of 20% or more
for the first three months of this year
compared to the first three months of
last year but one-third of all
businesses that responded to the survey
have seen sales dropped by 40 percent or
more in the first quarter of 2020 that
drop in sales has led to widespread
layoffs stat scan says 48% of businesses
in Quebec have been forced to lay off
some employees that's the highest in the
country the national average is 41
percent the Louis is in Saskatchewan
where just 34 percent of businesses have
been forced to lay off some employees
the hardest hit businesses are no
surprise here in the accommodation and
food service sector 68 percent of those
businesses have furloughed some
employees and in fact one in four
businesses in the accommodation and food
service sector have laid off all of
their workers 100 percent the sector
experiencing the fewest layoffs
that would be agriculture and fishery
just 14% of firms in that sector have
reported having to make any layoffs
Donathan alright david akin in ottawa
thank you
the UN's labor agency released a
snapshot of the global impact of cope at
19 it says nearly half the global
workforce is at risk of losing income
the International Labour Organization
projects 1.6 billion people could lose
their livelihoods because of kovat 19
lockdowns it says people doing informal
work with little support or job security
have lost about 60 percent of their
income during the first month of this
pandemic it says no income means no food
no security and no future for millions
of workers there's also some new data on
how the American economy is taking a hit
the GDP in the u.s. contracted 4.8% in
the first quarter it was the worst
quarter since the 2008 financial crisis
and the worst is yet to come because
that sad I looked at January through
March many businesses of course shut
down in mid-march it's all bad news for
Americans and for the US president
Donald Trump is up for re-election in
November and a dismal economy is the
last thing he wants right now more than
1 million people in the US are known to
have been infected with kovat 19 that's
not a full picture though because not
everyone is being tested about 60,000
people in the US are reported to have
died from kovat 19 and that makes up
more than a quarter of all kovat 19
related deaths in the world as Jackson
prosecco explains though the death rate
in the u.s. is probably not accurate
either it's been like this for weeks
thousands of deaths from COBIT 19 every
day tens of thousands of new cases in
all corners of the US you see the
decline has been slow at best and still
disgustingly high the official numbers
only tell part of the story according to
data from the US Centers for Disease
Control if you're under testing and
you're under counting the number of
cases then when people who haven't been
diagnosed with koba 19 and died nobody
is thinking about looking into that as a
possible cause of death
in seven states and New York City the
number of all recorded deaths from early
March to mid-april was far higher than
normal three hundred and twenty five
percent above normal in New York City
115 percent above normal in Maryland the
gap between reported deaths due to kovat
19:00 and other deaths is staggering in
New York City it means an extra 1,700
fatalities in Illinois an extra 700 in
total 9,000 additional deaths in just
seven hard-hit states you're gonna have
a hard time really trying to bring down
that mortality rate when you're not
counting it correctly to begin with and
there's another complication we continue
to see a number of positive signs that
the virus has passed its peak despite
claims from the White House that the
worst is over
experts say it may not be with the US
potentially nearing a plateau without a
sharp decline we know that the rate of
increase whether it's cases
hospitalizations or deaths the rate of
increase is declining but the overall
curve still shows an increase for the
shortcomings in testing there's good
news on the treatment front dr. Anthony
Fauci of the White House coronavirus
task force announced that clinical
trials of a drug called REM des Vere
have shown it's potentially effective in
helping Co vid 19 patients recover
faster Donna all right Jackson Prosecco
in Washington thanks a grim milestone
for the UK today it is now recorded the
second-highest number of deaths in
Europe after Italy more than 26,000
people are known to have died in the UK
from Kovac 19 the number jumped because
deaths in care homes and outside of
hospitals are now included in the count
and British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
has become a father again his girlfriend
Kerry Simon's gave birth to a son this
morning in London Johnson was at her
side
he's just recovered from coal bed 19 and
he's expected to take maternity leave
later this year the baby is believed to
be Johnson's sixth child and the third
to be born to a sitting British Prime
Minister this century there is a bit of
an update tonight on two Canadian
who have been detained in China for more
than 500 days China's foreign ministry
says they're in good health
businessmen Michael's pivara and Michael
Kovarik have been in detention since
December of 2018 and what is widely seen
as retaliation for the arrest of Huawei
executive mung Wong Jo in Vancouver on a
US warrant pivara and Kovarik were
allowed limited consular visits but that
stopped in January when China suspended
access to jails because of koban 19
tragedy and hope in Fort McMurray coming
up RCMP investigate a death as people
keep a close eye on those ice jams
RCMP in Fort McMurray Alberta are
investigating a death near the Athabasca
River it's one of the rivers with an ice
jam that's caused extensive flooding 20
kilometers of ice is forced about 13,000
people from their homes and put the area
under two states of emergency a
mandatory evacuation order is in place
in several areas this is the worst
flooding to hit the area in more than a
century
as Heather Eurex West reports there are
some signs of hope the ice is beginning
to clear Andrew wall is feeling numb in
the last few weeks he's dealt with kovat
19 restrictions an unspeakable tragedy
in his home province of Nova Scotia and
now a flood the area where we reside in
town is completely either submerged or
surrounded by water there is hopeful
news we are encouraged to see the ice
jams are beginning to clear on both the
Athabasca and the piéce rivers and that
water volumes are starting to go down
local officials expect water levels will
crest in the next few days around the
same time as the community marks four
years since the Fort McMurray wildfires
but the focus right now for those still
here is surviving the current crisis a
simple act of grocery shopping has
become even more challenging I got five
grocery stores downtown that don't exist
anymore we had two trucks coming
yesterday and shelves are almost empty
again and there is still the threat of
copán 19 on Tuesday Alberta health
officials relaxed restrictions in the
community but officials say this only
applies to people who are filling
sandbags dr. Hinshaw essentially gave a
waiver for them to to be closer together
and and also again we're gonna get them
protective equipment so that the risk is
reduced the province says it has sent
more than 100,000 masks to the region to
help protect evacuees both now and when
they return it's all a lot to take in on
Tuesday a friend brought Andrew wall a
dartboard
he plays competitively it was a small
act of kindness but in a time like this
it meant so much Heather your ex West
Global News Calgary
still ahead a busy market in Syria
turned into a place of mourning this is
the staggering devastation in
northwestern Syria after a fuel truck
was blown up near a busy market it
happened as people were shopping for
food to break their Ramadan fast more
than 40 people were killed 11 were
children the area was seized by Turkey
two years ago and it's blaming a Syrian
Kurdish militia group but there's been
no claim of responsibility in South
Korea a fire at a construction site is
one of the deadliest ever in that
country at least 38 people were killed
there are fears others could be trapped
inside the warehouse that's near the
capital it was under construction when
the fire broke out investigators suspect
it may have been triggered by an
explosion in an underground level all
the victims are believed to be
construction workers a much-loved
actor who got his start in Bollywood has
died this Aluna pittance nightmares
Irfan Khan went on to star in Hollywood
blockbusters such as Jurassic world
Slumdog Millionaire and the amazing
spider-man he died in Mumbai of a colon
infection in 2008 he was diagnosed with
a rare form of cancer and he underwent
months of treatment in the UK Khan was
just 53 years old and a beloved
community leader and humanitarian in
Halifax has passed away
Mel Butley er founded Food Bank programs
that have helped feed tens of thousands
of Nova Scotians he was awarded the
order of Nova Scotia and the Order of
Canada
boutonnieres family says he was
diagnosed with a rare form of blood
cancer in January and died of
complications yesterday his wife and
loved ones were by his side
lutely ur was 92 years old
open to serve while flattening the curve
next BC restaurants dish up a pandemic
plan
restaurants across the country have
either shut down completely or are
trying to survive doing takeout BC is
now looking at ways to get them back in
business
Robin Gill explains how this Vancouver
eatery is down to four staff in the
kitchen 30 servers and bartenders have
to be laid off but it's open to pick up
we're probably down about 90% in revenue
doing this sort of takeout delivery
model it's paying some bills but
nobody's getting ahead the restaurant
business in Canada is already a tough
slog according to the national industry
lobby group 80% will close within the
first five years the average restaurant
profit in Canada is about 4% so take
take a model that's pretty challenged to
begin with now add these kinds of
challenges in BC the industry is
pitching a new model for business
unusual the proposals include
temperature checks for staff and
customers when they arrive masks and
gloves for employees to pick up dishes
hand sanitizing stations plexiglass
between booth limiting groups to no more
than 10 and reducing the number of seats
by 50% to allow physical distancing to
put together a plan that deals with two
things essentially is is really really
high public safety standards that we've
probably never seen before because we
need that in order to have public
confidence but consumers can expect
fewer items on the menu and a bigger
bill at the end of a meal they're gonna
have to be be doing that with with the
market being receptive to paying more
for their food and beverage experiences
those restaurants that have agreed to
the changes and followed protocols will
have a certificate posted outside
because in this industry it's all about
survival in an economy that has become
stagnant hopefully by next year we
forget all about this reopening
restaurants will be phased in and the
industry will likely be forever changed
but it may be the only way to bring back
their employees and their customers
Robin Gill Global News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen captain Tom
Moore turns 100 tomorrow and so many
people of centum carts they filled the
whole of his grandson's school more has
raised more than 29 million pounds for
Britain's National Health Service by
walking lengths of its garden and today
on Twitter he said it is quite
extraordinary that I'm turning 100 it is
even more extraordinary that I'm doing
so with this many well-wishers and I am
in awe at the response my walking has
had to everyone who is donated sent
birthday cards and messages sincerely
thank you please stay home stay safe
tomorrow will be a good day
[Music]